Gotham City garage is a series that DC
just announced inspired by the hit
statue line from DC collectibles that
transforms your favorite DC heroines
into badass biker chicks
we've got co-writers Jackson Lansing and
Colin Kelly here to take us on a ride
through the new project essentially it's
an anti-fascist dystopian story where we
got to take all of the DC characters
that we love and make them all outlaws
and rebels and deer heads basically the
DC as we know no longer is exist this
isn't a parallel world this is still our
world but something critical happens
that bifurcated our time and it happened
about 30 years back so it happened pre
Superman and the idea is that whatever
happened pretty Superman wrecked the
planet to such a degree that now the
only city that's left is Gotham City but
Gotham City is no longer called Gotham
City it's called the Garlin and it's run
by Lex Luthor Mike to be her sits at the
top of it as a governor he has
programmed the entire population
assembled right along there with little
computers in your brain make you happy
make you hungry when he wants you to be
hungry makes mom sleep when you want so
we follow the rules exclusively and the
trick is when all this happened the
heroes that we know of the time they
were wiped out - or they just never
happened Batman never happened Superman
never happened
Wonder Woman is thought of they're like
a myth no one knows about these
characters they were never publicly
active in the way that the DC Universe
has had them for 30 years so terrifying
yeah it's a pretty scary kind of bad
place and in that place we need our hero
Kara Gordon not Kara Danvers so the same
girl raised completely differently in a
very very different context and she's
raised as the daughter to Jim Gordon who
is the head of the sinkhole Alexis which
is the third Lex Luthor secret police
and you have her sister Barbara Gordon
who is essentially the Oracle of this
organization and it's really great
because Tara were getting to approach
her as a young girl who doesn't know
who's like she doesn't know her destiny
which is very classic Supergirl but she
also doesn't know who she can be she
does know her powers she doesn't know
that she's part of this grand legacy
she's just this
girl kind of coming into this big world
fighting for what she believed in
okay so how did you guys draw
inspiration from the line of DC
collectibles that was the easiest from a
movie before it showed us they showed us
these beautiful designs and our instinct
just started going wild you know when we
first saw this stuff we were like oh wow
this is such a daunting task there's so
many elements here to play with and we
have so much respect for these
characters we absolutely have to use
something that's really special and then
we started looking at these designs and
we were like oh well what if we did this
and like look at those tattoos oh my god
clearly should got those at a prison
camp
oh my god yeah and I like all the
stories to started rolling out from
awesome all the fun of the fun of the
story of that we get to reinvest like
any character we want to hit and and do
so in a way that again like Superman and
Batman have never been around so what
did that mean for these characters what
I mean for a Batgirl what does that mean
for Harley Quinn right right so Harley
is actually one of my favorite
characters just in the regular DC use so
getting the chance to do this version of
her that's a little bit more while a lot
a bit more self actualized but most
importantly if the Harley Quinn that is
getting to evolve without being
dependent on the Joker's great she came
from herself first in her relationship
with the garden for relationship with
Lex Luthor and from that kind of growth
she's the one who's going to be
inspiring the Joker oh my gosh I love
that I really get to like approach her
for a really honest really true really
powerful and then we get to look at the
Joker from this very kind of very Harley
Quinn place where he's always trying to
prove himself to her rather than the
other way around and if she's the one
who sort of always like kind of shunkan
him off to the side and and everyone to
all realizing like oh maybe like this
guy but like also like you like that's
been really fun to do if I use actors
that's a great question I think we have
a really cool take on Catwoman that I
can almost not talk about without
getting too spoilery about it when we
get to her in Episode seven and eight
you're going to get a lot of really cool
information about what's going on with
her but I think our Catwoman has some
really cool hidden depths and I think
the one that will throw just a tease is
that she's not Selina Kyle what what it
means to be cat
in this world isn't necessarily
dependent on being Selina and how that
relationship plays out is I think going
to be a very interesting wonder one you
guys I cannot wait for this series it
sounds like it's going to be incredible
thank you so much for sitting down with
me Roger I have one more question and
that is when does this launch August
16th we're going to be bi-weekly until
October and then we're gonna start going
weekly so after that you'll get Gotham
City Garage like every week work starts
digital goes physical very nice to see
you done yeah we're greatly excited
thank you guys thank you hey that's a
preview of Gotham City Garage and here's
the full list of DC comics you can pick
up this week
[Music]
[Music]
that's the news for now but make sure
you update your poll list for this week
and check back with us for more news
straight from San Diego comic-con also
this year we're going to be holding the
first ever DC all access panel Thursday
at San Diego comic-con so if you're at
the con come by say hi and see a really
cool panel we'll see you tomorrow Super
Friends